quando silvia davide i ragazzi dello
staff di tex bari a quelli faccio i
migliori auguri per questa prima
edizione mi hanno proposto di parlare di
resilienza e mafia in un primo momento
ho pensato ma
chiedere a uno che fa che ha fatto
antimafia che ha fondato un movimento
giovani antimafia di parlare di
resilienza in questo campo
sarebbe come aspettarsi che dracula
potesse diventare il presidente
dell'avis o che totò riina presidente
appunto della mia associazione al mio
posto e ci ho riflettuto parecchio v vi
confesso che ero molto perplesso su
questa cosa cercavo di capire di entrare
dentro questa parola resilienza e me la
sono ripetuta tanti giorni fino a quando
non ho capito che effettivamente se si è
data a questa parola e non un'altra
perché pensare resilienza da me evoca
tante altre parole positive e tante
altre cose positive tipo la speranza la
crescita il rinnovamento che cosa può
succedere in un ambiente come quello
della criminalità organizzata
cosa può succedere in un ambiente dove
la morte regna sovrana dove la vita è
l'eccezione dove il sacrificio e la
regola e dove la felicità è davvero un
qualcosa che non potrai mai raggiungere
e alla quale non potrà mai aspirare
ebbene c'è un senso c'è un senso perché
dentro la parola resilienza c'è il
concetto stesso del relativismo tutto è
relativo tutto è relativo in campo di
resilienza si mescolano le carte non
capisci più che ti è la guardia e chi è
il lato
proprio perché non ai parametri non hai
per utilizzare un gergo informatico il
codec per leggere questi files files che
sono mutevoli cambiano ogni giorno e
appunto si contaminano a vicenda
ebbene oggi parliamo di resilienza
negative nicola diceva titolo di questa
mia di questo mio spicci doveva essere
the dark side of the silence
io mi sono permesso una piccola licenza
come vedete anche in grafica ho voluto
riflettere
queste due parole
sono molto simili sono hasson anti onere
silence l'altro resistance
resistance e quindi vi racconterò queste
storie vedrete come sono molto ambigue
ambiguo nel vero senso del termine non
si capisce dove il bene dov'è il male
che la vittima e chi il carnefice
paolo rosario de stefano
vedete sorridente
così di primo acchitto non non possiamo
sapere chi è questo signore eppure
proviamo un attimo a ad aprire
lo diciamo l'ottica di questa fotografia
39 anni vedete come si abbraccia con gli
uomini della squadra mobile di reggio
calabria che lo hanno appena tratto in
arresto dopo quattro anni che lo
inseguivano lui il capo di un clan dei
de stefano persona molto intelligente
affabile inserito in quella cosiddetta
borghesia mafiosa reggina che per anni
ha fatto sì che la ndrangheta potesse
diventare quella mafia che oggi può
essere a tutto titolo la mafia più forte
del mondo perché non è una mafia perché
l'organizzazione criminale nel puro
senso del termine che vive che vive di
un solido legame col territorio perché
esprime nel bene e nel male anche le
energie interne a quello stesso
territorio
prende ciò che di male c'è e lo rende
ancora più malvagio prende ciò che di
buono c'è e lo conferma ad essa vedete è
stato arrestato nel 2009 era tra i 30
latitanti più pericolosi d'italia
condannata al 41 bis
scarcerato dopo solo sei anni per meriti
accademici il dottor paolo de stefano da
un mese e un laureato cum laude in
giurisprudenza è stato scarcerato
dopo solo sei anni di detenzione
potrebbe essere un buon esempio di
resilienza
pentimento forse chi lo sa di fronte a
dio non lo sappiamo di fronte agli
uomini certo che no perché non è
diventato collaboratore di giustizia ma
ha pagato come si dice in gergo tecnico
il suo prezzo con lo stato ha scontato
la sua pena
filippo ceravolo
filippo ceravolo 19 anni studente una
sera rientrava a casa con un ragazzo che
gli stava dando semplicemente un
passaggio lui filippo figlio di un
venditore ambulante di soriano calabro
un piccolo paese che sta inerpicato
sulle montagne del del vibonese nella
zona delle serre lì dove ci sono i
monaci certosini nella serie che stanno
appunto nella certosa di serra san bruno
e soriano calabro un paese lì vicino
chiede un passaggio al
a un giovane compaesano
il killer sbaglia e uccide filippo il
vero obiettivo di quella esecuzione era
quell altro ragazzo
fino ancora ad oggi non c'è nessun
colpevole
ai funerali di questo giovane onesto
figlio di un venditore ambulante
c'era soltanto una corona di fiori dei
colleghi di suo papà insomma paghe oggi
lotta per nel nome di un figlio che è
morto per sbaglio solo perché si trovava
nel posto sbagliato nel momento
sbagliato
anna frucci
lei ha una storia terribile
e secondo me la resilienza fatta persona
questo che vedete il suo figlio un
giovane ex seminarista di philadelphia
c'è questa cosa strana avete al sud ogni
tanto ce l'hanno dei nomi di città che
sembrano da altre parti abbiamo
philadelphia però e non è la fiera del
fia statunitense ma sta in provincia di
vibo valentia questo ex seminarista è
sparito è sparito nel 2006 io ero da
poco tempo insieme ad altri ragazzi
impegnato quello che oggi si chiama
ammazzateci tutti e conosco questa mamma
che lottava per cercare di capire perché
a suo figlio non avessero dato neanche
la possibilità l'onore di poter avere
una sepoltura
sono quei casi che noi chiamiamo in
gergo lupare bianche
non si sa che ambienti magari
frequentasse questo ragazzo si dice che
sia entrato magari in un meccanismo che
lo ha purtroppo portato ad avere una
condanna scritta sulla propria testa ma
hanno condannato questa mamma a non
poter avere il cadavere del figlio e di
poter portarci un fiore il fratello di
questo ragazzo cristian galati
ha cercato
in tanti modi di sapere come andassero
le cose per il suo fratello come fossero
andate davvero le cose
che cosa ci fosse dietro
lo contattano sul messenger
e gli scrivono sai forse sappiamo
qualcosa sul tuo fratello tre anni dopo
era il 2009
e
all'inizio lui non ci crede qualche
giorno dopo con un'altra scusa non
contattano altre persone fingendosi una
ragazza lo invitano ad andare in un
posto sulle montagne e lì vicino
li massacrano la testa a martellate e
gli danno fuoco vivo
dopo due mesi di agonia è morto qui a
bari in ospedale e quella mamma oggi
piange due figli di una resilienza molto
molto molto strada
questo è un ragazzo di 24 anni
questo è il suo profilo facebook è un
elettrauto un lavoratore onesto entra in
contatto con una ragazza
che non rivela il suo nome
e che pare non avesse detto di essere
sposata
scompare il 23 febbraio del 2012
scompare non dà gioia tauro ma da
melicucco che un paese che sta a quattro
chilometri dal mio che e polistena e
dove appunto la protagonista di questo
caso di resilienza e simona napoli lui
era a casa di questa ragazza e non ha
mai più fatto ritorno a casa a gioia
tauro
perché come racconterà simona
il padre
il fratello è un parente lo hanno ucciso
simona napoli denuncia la sua famiglia
contribuisce con il suo atto di estremo
coraggio
a far ritrovare il corpo perché poi
hanno confessato dove era stato nascosto
il corpo di
di fabrizio pioli
e cosa fa poco tempo dopo resilienza
ha rinunciato al programma di protezione
ed è ritornata a casa col marito
vedete un po
ho provato a pensare a quali potessero
essere gli elementi di congiunzione
per provare a teorizzare una sorta di
resilienza mafiosa perché tra tutte
queste storie
simona
cristiane valentino galati
il ragazzo di soriano calabro ceravolo e
il nostro dottore boss di reggio
calabria de stefano sono degli elementi
comuni il primo è la colpa
colpevole cd20 ucci nasce in una
famiglia mafiosa spesso ci nasci e poi
lo sei anche perché continui non vuoi
cadere lontano dall'albero quindi
contini per una sorta di logica della
natura a perpretare quello che ti hanno
insegnato a fare sin da quando eri
bambino nella culla al tempo stesso
quella stessa colpa che diventa senso di
colpa che spesso ti può spingere invece
a reagire a darti forza nel momento in
cui è toccato il punto più basso nel
momento in cui tuoi cari hanno bloccato
il punto più basso perdendo addirittura
la vita a reagire a reagire
il secondo elemento è l'onore vedete
l'ora è secondo me una parola che i
mafiosi hanno sottratto al vocabolario
degli onesti
noi siamo persone da una persona d'onore
noi siamo uomini e donne d'onore non i
mafiosi però abbiamo questa cosa che ci
accomuna
noi abbiamo l'onore di appartenere a
delle terre meravigliose il sud io io
vengo dalla calabria qui siamo in puglia
ieri ero in sicilia
e
l'onore l'onore è un qualcosa che nel
loro linguaggio è un bene supremo viene
prima ancora della famiglia
che il terzo elemento
quando questi tre elementi si mescolano
colpa onore e famiglia sia nel bene sia
nel male avviene la resilienza
questa è una formula un po azzardata
vedete pensate colpa onore e famiglia
sono tre elementi che tra di loro
potrebbero significare
sicuramente molto più male che bene però
spesso e volentieri sono quelle cose che
spingono una mamma a lottare per sapere
qual è la verità per suo dire che fine
ha fatto suo figlio il fratello che
viene contattato sul messenger e che
cerca di farsi verità e giustizia da
solo perché purtroppo lo stato non
arriva perché purtroppo lo stato non
arrivò
la colpa la colpa di essere nato in una
famiglia mafiosa
di essere stato arrestato anche però
devo ritenere la colpa perché sia
scontato
sei anni di carcere ha pagato il suo
prezzo con la giustizia
e allora anche il dottor paolo rosario
de stefano ha solo la colpa di essere
nato in una famiglia mafiosa è stato già
rieducato sono bastati sei anni
io sinceramente visto che ne capisce
adesso
spererei che
contribuisca in qualche modo a a far
luce su quello che sta succedendo a
reggio calabria
che possa dare paolo de stefano anche
una spiegazione a quella stagione dove
sono morte mille persone una guerra di
mafia
che negli anni 90 è culminata poi con
l'uccisione di un giudice che era il
giudice antonino scopelliti e che era
con il quale doveva affrontare la
pubblica accusa in cassazione nel
maxiprocesso contro cosa nostra il
processo di falcone e borsellino il pool
il pool antimafia di palermo di
caponnetto di chinnici
dolore
l'onore di martino ceravolo il papà di
filippo io l'ho conosciuto martino è una
persona umile eccezionale
e
le prime volte mi diceva sai aldo qual è
il problema che io da quando è morto mio
figlio non vivo più ovviamente perché
nella legge della natura i figli devono
sotterrare i genitori non i genitori
figli
mio figlio aveva 19 anni era mio figlio
maschio
mia figlia non non vive più una sorella
più piccola
mia moglie non vive più
devo mi ha confessato anche questa cosa
ma sto smettendo
e quello non ore è quello l'onore di
lottare contro una legge stupida
che va purtroppo a colpire due volte una
famiglia che già purtroppo non
entrandoci nulla con la mafia purtroppo
viene condannata a due volte perché per
poter essere riconosciuto vittima di
mafia filippo ceravolo ci sono voluti
tre anni per quale motivo perché c'è una
legge troppo scrupolosa e quella appunto
del
che regolamenta questo settore che
quello delle vittime di mafia
per i quali per il fino al quarto grado
di parentela
tu non puoi beneficiare di questo fondo
se hai appunto fino al quarto grado di
parentela dei parenti che sono coinvolti
nell'organizzazione criminale io vi dico
che io che faccio antimafia che la
faccio da dieci anni
evito di andare a ormai ai matrimoni dei
miei cugini di terzo grado solo per il
timore
di poter essere fotografato dal ros dei
carabinieri e definire in un'informativa
della dda di reggio calabria piuttosto
che di palmi perché anche io i parenti
mafiosi perché ce li abbiamo tutti i
parenti mafiosi ma ciascuno di noi
decide come vivere
ciascuno di noi decidere come vivere
se ovviamente fortunato se nasce in una
famiglia come la mia come quella di
silvia che ho visto a 13 anni entrare
timidamente in un forum online che era
il forum di ammazzateci tutti che oggi è
qui tra i ragazzi dello staff
però se nasce nella famiglia sbagliata
tu cosa puoi fare ecco puoi cercare di
capire perché e poi entrare in contatto
con delle realtà tipo la nostra tipo
ammazzateci tutti puoi cercare di stare
dalla parte dello stato nonostante non
convenga stare dalla parte dello stato
lo dico con rassegnazione dopo dieci
anni di impegno
quando 66 minacciato al telefono la
notte ti arrivano le telefonate parlo di
me
vai a fare le tue denunce paghi un
avvocato affronti un processo e quando
arrivi di fronte al giudice il giudice
tifa ema pecora lei da quanto tempo era
che faceva antimafia così come la
chiamate voi questo succede davvero
lo sto rivelando per la prima volta io
per rispetto nei confronti della
giustizia che per me sacro non l'avevo
mai detto questo io giudice e al tempo
era il 2010 cinque anni e come pecora in
cinque anni dovrebbe averci fatto il
callo a queste cose
ricevere una telefonata alla notte no
giudice io ho denunciato perché erano
c'erano persone che chiamavano con un
accento sconosciuto chiamavano alle 3 di
notte sa non è normale e dicono che
vengono a casa e ti ammazzano e io
faccio una denuncia da buon cittadino
non penso che abbia fatto qualcosa
contro il dovere di ogni cittadino
italiano ma conosco magistrati che sono
sotto scorta loro sì che sono in
pericolo
lei queste cose quando gliele annunciano
mica gliele fanno e poi perché ha
risposto con un sms perché i signori che
hanno minacciato hanno sbagliato forse
erano ubriachi questi ragazzi che poi
scoperto che chi fossero uno aveva anche
precedenti penali
forse hanno sbagliato
dice perché mi è arrivata una chiamata
un messaggio con il numero scoperto
quindi non era anonimo e io ho mandato
un messaggio e sono stato resiliente a
modo mio
caro coniglio se non ha gli attributi
per venirmi ad ammazzare davvero dimmi
dove stai perché vengo e ti ammazzo io
prima
bene per quella cosa per quelle sms
i due signori che minacciavano sono
stati assolti perché io non ero
preoccupato perché le minacce che avevo
ricevuto di notte sul cellulare svariate
volte non sa non destavano
preoccupazione non mi devo preoccupare
ciascuno giudica bene ciò che conosce è
solo di questo è buon giudice bene io
dieci anni dopo ammazzateci tutti il 19
ottobre del 2005 questa è la nostra
prima apparizione pubblica
vi posso dire che se le cose vanno in
questi termini
e anche se oggi ho provato a parlare di
resilienza negative e forse anche io non
conosco la ndrangheta grazie